- I think that it's
really important
to point out Donald
Trump yesterday,
I heard him say that he
was tired of Joe Biden
talking about how
Russia has nuclear power
and it is a nuclear force.
And it sounds like, you
know, when you say that,
that you're scared and
president Trump said
you know what Joe
Biden should be saying,
we are a nuclear power
and we know what to do.
And that I think therein
lies the difference
is that Donald
Trump was no wimp.
He wasn't anyone who
just said you know,
I wanna bring troops
home and avoid war.
He built up the
defense department.
He built up America's power.
He used the power
with Soleimani.
He was really able to
show an unpredictability
when it came to using
America's power,
but he has his criteria.
And this is I think, a
really important point.
What is best for the US?
(light tempo music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
in joining me today
is the former US
ambassador to Germany,
as well as the former
acting Director
of National Intelligence
or these great
at least great for now,
United States of America and
my friend and Californian.
We're gonna have to get
into that, Rich Grenell.
Welcome back to
the Rubin report.
- Dave, thanks for having me.
Always a pleasure.
- Let's just do the California
thing quick in one minute.
What the high hell are
you doing there still man.
- I love this place.
I can't leave.
I can't abandon it.
It's bad.
Look, today's the
filing deadline
for people running
for governor, senate,
congressional races,
all the races.
Doesn't look like we're gonna
have any major candidate
running against Newsom.
And I think that's just more
of a commentary on the fact
that the system here is broken.
They do mail-in ballots.
Democrats completely
rule this place
like a third world country.
And so therefore we really
don't have competition.
- You know, Rick, I
knew it was bad in Cali
When I was calling people
to say I was leaving.
And I thought you were
gonna be the one guy,
because you were trying to
clean up the roles there.
And you're still trying to
do a whole bunch of stuff.
And I know how much
you love California.
You've been there forever,
but I was calling people
to say, I'm leaving.
And everyone was like
oh great, you know,
you should go.
It's time to go get outta dodge.
And you were the only person
I thought was gonna say stay,
and you go, I get it.
And then I was like all
right, I'm outta here.
By the way Rick,
every time I mention
California on the show,
I put money into to this jar.
And at the end of the year,
I'm gonna be handing
a whole bunch of cash.
And I'm throwing in a couple
thousand dollars of my money
for somebody that's
willing to leave California
and migrate to Florida.
So.
- I thought you were gonna say
for somebody who needs
to help pay taxes
because they stayed there.
And so I'll gladly
take the money.
- No, I am not paying
your taxes to king Newsom.
Okay, but let's
get onto the stuff
that I really wanted to
talk to you about this week
because obviously
there's this whole
Russia/Ukraine situation.
This is what you're
an expert it in,
as an ambassador and on
the intelligence side
and all of that.
So I thought maybe we could
start by just doing a little,
a little 101 on what you think
American foreign
policy should be like.
So before we just jump into,
before we get into the specifics
of what's happening
in Russia and Ukraine,
just generally what you think
America's role in
the world should be,
and maybe how it was
when you were working
with that Orange guy
versus how it is now,
let's just start there
and then we'll jump
to the specifics.
- Yeah, look, you know,
I think that the America first
policy is a fantastic one
and it doesn't
mean America alone.
And it doesn't mean just simply
that we bring troops home
and we ignore crises
around the world.
I think what America
first means is just that,
is that we put America first.
We think about our
US National Security.
That's the criteria, what is
good for US National Security,
but it also means that our
allies have to stand up
and we encourage them to do so.
So it's why we removed
our us troops in Somalia,
'cause we said to Kenya,
hey, can you kind of police
your own neighborhood?
It's why we wanted the
Europeans to do more.
And I think there's
an admission,
a tacit admission from
the Germans right now
in terms of their policy,
that they believe that
they on the wrong track
for 10, 16 years of Merkel.
They now are completely flipped.
They're better than
the Senate Democrats.
They're better than Joe Biden
because there's an admission now
that wow, not paying your
NATO fair share of 2%
was a huge mistake.
So what did the Germans do?
They decided to say
we're gonna pay it all at
once in one year to catch up.
This is a huge admission
that they have been on the
wrong track for 16 years.
Then they turn
around and they say
we gotta stop this
Russian pipeline.
This is historic.
This is unprecedented.
Don't forget just
a few months ago,
not very long ago,
Senate Democrats, the
Biden administration,
and the government of
chancellor Merkel in Germany
all came together to say
drop the sanctions on Putin,
on the Russian Nord
Stream 2 pipeline
because they all said
this may encourage him.
If we squeeze him too much,
then he's gonna of lash out.
Well, obviously they were wrong
and they completely
got it upended.
And so the sanctions
should have been put on,
or stayed on we should say,
but the Democrats, the
Biden administration
should have kept
that pressure on.
And I think that we'd
have a different scenario,
but when Putin is
looking at Afghanistan
and by the way, if people
are not talking enough
about the policy that
Biden put in place
to drop the Houthis from
the terrorist watch list.
As soon as they did that Dave,
we had a couple of months later,
what did the Houthis do?
They were bombarding the UAE.
Abu Dhabi was receiving
missiles from the Houthis.
Now this was by official
Washington, largely ignored.
There wasn't a correlation made
between hey you know,
Joe Biden and the
Biden administration,
all the Democrats
just took the Houthis
off the terrorist list,
and what happened?
They started acting
like terrorists.
And so you literally have
to push official Washington
to see that these weak
policies translate globally
into terrible situations.
I don't think it's
too much to say
that Joe Biden's
weakness is causing war.
It's scandal, destruction,
and we have to be able to
shake the Senate Democrats
because the Germans
now see that.
And it's, I never thought
I would see it in my day.
And they're certainly not
saying Rick Grenell was right,
Donald Trump was right,
but they're coming awful close.
- So let's stick with that
Germany situation for a minute,
because so you were ambassador
to Germany under Trump.
And if you listen to the
media throughout all of that,
you know, Trump was mean and
scaring people all the time
and you went in there and you
weren't listening to anybody.
And the other ambassador
wasn't happy with you
and all of this stuff.
However things were
basically working
in terms of all of our
international agreements.
And we were at least
trying to encourage people
to pay a bit more,
which as you just said
now they're catching up with,
did everything shift
overnight basically,
once Biden took over?
- I think that there's
a combination of
once Biden took over
and once Merkel was gone,
it was relatively
at the same time.
And you know, Merkelism
really didn't work.
We had 16 years of,
and I'm passionate
about this subject
is that I believe
that chancellor Merkel
in making her policy
Germany first,
she decided to move the German
trans-Atlantic relationship
away from the west
instead of making a
Western facing Alliance
where you stand with the
west and you do things
that benefit the west.
She decided to have a foreign
policy like Switzerland
and be everybody's friend
and to sell cars, you know,
in Moscow and Beijing and
Teran and everywhere else.
And don't forget when
I arrived in Germany,
I was walking around one day
and I walked past this
hotel youth hostile,
and I looked over
and it was literally,
I'm not exaggerating,
the property of North Korea
in the middle of Berlin.
And I went back to the
embassy and I was like
what the hell?
There's a north Korean
hotel youth hostile
in the middle of Berlin.
I mean, they're under
international sanctions.
This is illegal.
And they're, and you know,
everybody at the state
department was like
yeah, but I guess we've
allowed that to happen.
No and I said, no,
no, no, no guessing,
this is unacceptable.
So I took it to
chancellor Merkel
and you know there
were a lot of excuses,
oh, it's not really us.
It's this management company.
And I said, I don't care.
It's in the middle of
Berlin, shut it down.
You're violating UN sanctions.
They eventually shut it down.
They weren't happy with
me for pointing that out,
but I wasn't happy with them
for violating
international sanctions.
My point in telling you
this is that they've moved
away from the west for 16 years
while the German Marshall
fund has just applauded them
as you know, this
great economic power.
And yet I think
that a difference.
You can bifurcate the
trans-Atlantic Alliance
from the Western facing
Alliance, the Western Alliance,
and Merkel decided to just
be a part of this you know,
trans-Atlantic Alliance,
which was not Western facing.
She's the one who moved
Germany and Europe
away from the west.
And now I think they're
scrambling to say yikes,
I think we might have
encouraged war in Ukraine.
- Okay, so with all
of that in mind,
none of this happened
for the four years
under the guy that
you worked for.
And everyone kept saying oh,
but Trump is Putin's puppet
and all of these things.
And yet oddly Putin
made a move on Crimea
when Joe Biden was
vice president,
and then he cooled
it off for four years
and then made a move
when Biden was president.
Are any of these
things connected
or am I a crazy
conspiracy theorist here?
- I know you personally,
you're not crazy,
but don't forget that we
should also put in there though
that Putin moved on
George, under Bush,
under President Bush.
This is not a partisan statement
to say that you've got to
be able to put America first
and articulate the responses
of the US government.
And you know,
I think that it's really
important to point out
Donald Trump yesterday,
I heard him say
that he was tired of
Joe Biden talking about
how Russia has nuclear power
and it is a nuclear force.
And it sounds like you
know, when you say that,
that you're scared,
and president Trump said
you know what Joe
Biden should be saying,
we are a nuclear power
and we know what to do.
And that I think therein
lies the difference
is that Donald
Trump was no wimp.
He wasn't anyone who
just said you know,
I wanna bring troops
home and avoid war.
He built up the
defense department,
he built up America's power.
He used the power
with Soleimani.
He was really able to,
to show an unpredictability
when it came to using
America's power,
but he has his criteria.
And this is I think, a
really important point.
What is best for the US?
And I'll finish by
saying, you know,
the state department
needs to learn this lesson
because when you talk
about America first
and all of the great things
about what that means
to be an America first advocate,
it doesn't mean America alone.
And there's a way to
articulate America first.
And I believe this passionately,
that America first helps
our allies and others.
When America is out front,
trying to push forward
democracy, human rights,
the rule of law, guess what?
Every economy benefits,
we see that, inflation
is spiky now,
economies are not doing well.
When America puts itself first,
capitalism and the
rule of law thrive,
that brings up
every other country.
We should have state
depart ambassadors overseas
who articulate why an America
first policy is good for them.
There should be no
apologies about this.
It's better to
have America first
than to allow Russia or China
to put themselves first.
And I think what we've seen
from 16 years of Merkel,
it's much better
for America first
than to put Germany first.
- So who do you think Biden
is putting first right now?
I mean, we, it seems
like a lifetime ago,
but literally only
three weeks ago,
right before this
whole thing started.
We had about a two week window
of every day where Biden,
it sounded like he was basically
acting as Putin's PR guy.
He kept being like well,
he's probably gonna go,
maybe he'll go.
These are the 16 things
we don't want him to do.
Here's a bunch of
stuff he can do.
I mean, what is our policy
at this point?
- Look, I don't wanna
get too philosophical,
or theoretical here,
but the opposite of
America first is consensus,
especially consensus
with the Europeans.
And I spent eight
years at the UN
and I can tell you inside
the security council,
that any time there's
a policy or a statement
coming out of the
security council,
it's the lowest
common denominator
of what 15 countries believe.
And it's not putting
America first,
certainly not putting
democracy human rights,
the rule of law first.
And so Joe Biden is trapped
in official Washington ideas
that he wants to be
loved by the world.
He talks like you know,
I know all these world leaders.
He really prioritizes the
applause from the globalists.
And so when you think about it,
he really wants the
Europeans to be pleased.
The reason he dropped the
sanctions on Nord Stream 2
is 'cause Merkel and the Germans
at the time asked him to.
He maximized being
with the Germans,
being with the Europeans,
having them love him.
Look no further
than the Iran deal.
Iran deal two.
And now we see the
Europeans saying
wait a minute, this deal,
we're gonna have
to put it on ice
because it's going south.
When the Europeans are saying
we need to stop this process,
And the Biden team is not
the one calling it first,
we've got a big problem when
you're behind the Europeans,
but this is the policy.
Now I can go through you know,
each area of the world.
Look at Venezuela policy now.
We're moving and transitioning
into engagement again,
which already failed
with the Venezuelan
simply because there's a
bunch of Latin countries
that want us to do that.
And Joe Biden is leaning in
and letting them
determine that policy.
The same thing in the Balkans.
I worked very hard
on cost of Serbia.
We had four economic agreements.
You know what the policy is now,
let the Europeans
lead on this issue.
And you know, this is
the whole 1990s crowd
filled with NGOs that
loved to write white papers
and tell rich people
to give them money
to think about these issues.
But they're not
making sense at all.
- Do you think
that these people,
without getting too far
into the philosophical part,
then do you think that,
that he at least has
competent people?
I mean when you listen
to Kamala Harris
talk about this stuff, you know,
Ukraine is small.
Russia is big.
Even Tony Blinken,
I mean, all of, they
don't competent to me.
Putting aside that you may have
a philosophical disagreement
with them on what US
strengths should be
or something like that.
Do they strike you
as competent people?
- But a friend in need
is a friend indeed Dave.
And look, you know,
they're not competent.
And I blame the Sacramento media
for allowing Kamala
Harris as a woman
and as a black person to rise
and win all of these
different offices,
simply because of her identity.
She wasn't qualified.
She doesn't have the capacity.
And I honestly will
double down on that.
If you look,
there's no possible way,
Susan Rice and Ron Klain
did not prepare her
with a good book
of what to say and what to
do and what the policy was.
I don't think it was
a lack of preparation.
I think it is a capacity issue
that she doesn't
understand these issues.
She's been allowed
to rise to the top
without any vetting
from the media.
There's been no push until
she got into the presidential,
and then the national media
a little bit were like
wait a minute, you're
not really ready.
And so she imploded,
but the Sacramento media
allowed her just to you know,
catapult and take over.
I don't think she's qualified.
I think Anthony Blinken
should have been fired
after Afghanistan.
I don't understand
why he's still around.
He's totally weak.
Wendy Sherman, the deputy
at the state department,
you know, her nickname is
what do you want Wendy.
When she goes into negotiations,
she gives away the store.
She did it in North Korea,
in Iran, with Russia.
I don't know how many times
we're gonna put her forward.
She's the terrible negotiator
for the United States.
And then, you know, Susan
Rice is behind the scenes
supposedly doing
domestic policy,
which she's not qualified for.
But I think she's
pulling the string
of all of these other positions.
Remember Susan Rice,
when she was national
security advisor,
had two deputies at the NSC.
One was Avril Haine,
who runs the intelligence
program as DNI,
and the other was
Anthony Blinken.
Who's now running
the state department.
So diplomacy and intelligence
all are really under Susan Rice.
They're her deputies.
She chose them.
And that just means Obama's
pulling the strings.
You know, there's
this philosophy,
and I think I agree with it
that Barack Obama couldn't
be the far left progressive
that he really wanted to be
because as a black man,
he was very nervous
about being, you know,
somebody who was in the middle
and being accepted by
all the polite sides.
And I find that to be a phony,
you know, kind of analysis,
but nevertheless, he
wasn't as progressive
as people said that
he was going to be,
but now unleashed in
this Obama third term
with a puppet like Biden,
I think the reality is that
Susan Rice and Ron Klain,
and everybody from the
Obama administration
is back into this Biden team,
that the Obama third
term is unleashed.
And they really are
just using Joe Biden
as a puppet and as an empty suit
to kind of let go and really try
all these hard left
progressive ideas.
Since it's imploding,
I think they now
have a good scapegoat
where they can say you know,
oh, Joe messed it up.
And maybe they'll try to adjust.
See them a little
bit trying to adjust,
but they're not
getting it fast enough.
- By the way,
what you're saying is
not like some crazy idea
that Obama wanted
the third term.
I mean, there is
that famous interview
of him saying boy, I wish
I could have a third term
where I was behind the scenes,
basically acting as
the puppet master.
I mean it's his words.
- Yeah.
- So, you know, you're not just,
you're not just pulling
this out of nowhere.
Do you think that
this mainly boils down
to America's energy sector?
I mean, if you just listen
to what we're talking about
suddenly in the last week
and gas prices going crazy,
$8 in Los Angeles,
really nuts stuff,
that they keep now saying
well, this is the time
for the green new deal.
This the time for electric cars.
That in some ways,
this is exactly
what they wanted.
- It's scary to think that
they would view every,
everything that's happening
and somehow come
up with the idea,
that they gotta get more
progressive and more lefty,
but-
- But they always do, right.
- I think they are.
I think they are.
I think that they're
reading this and saying
this is our opportunity.
It's crazy to think about
that they are not looking
at the highest inflation
and the highest gas prices.
And the fact that the
American people are you know,
overwhelmingly saying this is
a disastrous administration,
worse than Jimmy Carter,
the numbers keep going down.
You've even got some Democrats
now rising up and saying
you know, this blaming Putin
for the high gas prices
is ridiculous.
But you know,
you can't talk
about these issues
without talking about the
duty full media in Washington.
I mean, they're
allowing this to happen.
I mean, the New
York times, CNN, AP,
the Washington Post
are literally working
for the ruling party.
If we saw this happening
in another country,
we would call it out.
We would say you
don't have free media.
You have official media
of the democratic party
of the ruling party
of the president.
And there's no question
that the New York Times
and the Washington
post and the AP
work for the Democrats.
They can't critique the
Democrats to save their life.
And I think this is the crisis
that we find ourselves in,
because if you stay in
Washington like Joe Biden does,
and all of his people, you know,
Washington is exploding.
It's getting, every time you go,
there's a new crane
and a new building,
and the budgets
are getting bigger,
and $30 trillion
in national debt.
The joke is now on us that
live outside of Washington.
Why do we keep expecting
the media who live there,
the politicians who live there,
the lobbyists who live there,
they're never gonna
tear down their city.
They want a bigger, better city.
The only way to drain the swamp
is to dig trenches
with fresh water
and get that muck out.
And that means we gotta
start sending people
who don't wanna live,
work, and go to church
in Washington, DC.
We need people who
want their social life
back in their home districts.
So they go, they
vote, and they leave.
I will tell you two
people who do that,
and that I admire.
You know, there's more than two,
but the two that I see
constantly doing that
is Ron Johnson and Ted Cruz.
Their lives are back
in their home states.
And that includes
their social life.
And so they're not
part of Washington
and they can make better
decisions because of it.
- Do you think Trump
has any regrets
related to not
draining the swamp
as maybe more-
I mean, clearly the swamp
still exists, right?
He's he's not president
and the swamp exists.
Do you think there were more
things that he could have done,
or it was almost just an
impossible thing to do
within four years
or maybe that he didn't even
fully grasp the severity
of it, how entrenched it was,
and what he was
really up against.
- So I would say
this is my opinion.
I have not had this conversation
with president Trump fully.
I've had it a little
bit on the sides,
but I think by the end
of the administration,
by the end of the four years,
there was an admission
that you really have to
dig deep in Washington
into the agencies
and get your people.
You remember when
Donald Trump came,
he had told me that
he had never stayed
in Washington DC overnight
until the week of
his inauguration.
So he was a true outsider.
He had participated in
some of the you donations
for both sides
and the processes,
but he was a true outsider.
And so coming in as an outsider,
he was thinking
like an outsider.
And he thought you know,
I gotta get the
White House, right.
I gotta get the loyalist there.
And you run the government
from the White House.
Over time, I think he realized
wait a minute, you
gotta really get
into the agencies and dig deep
and get your people in there.
And so there was an admission
that we had to do more of that.
You know, I blame the people
that were really around him
in the very beginning,
not to say wait a minute,
you gotta have loyalists
across the board.
But I think that lesson
was learned through time
and would've been
fixed in a second term.
- So I wanna go
more towards that,
but I just wanna back
up for one second
on the Russia/Ukraine stuff.
When you hear from some
of your counterparts
that are probably still in
some of these ambassadorships
and still overseas,
are people quietly saying to you
boy, we sure do wish that
Orange guy was still around
because this wouldn't
have happened.
'Cause it seems
fairly obvious to me.
- Yeah.
- That this would
not be happening if
Trump was president.
- Absolutely.
It's across the
board all around,
I'll even go a
little bit further,
I'm getting messages
every single day
from foreign service officers
at the state department
who are saying what a
terrible mess we have.
They're not happy with Blinken.
They see this as weakness.
I mean, this is a real problem.
And they see it.
And these are people
that I know personally
did not vote for
president Trump,
because I have great
relationships with them.
And they've told me,
and we've sparred
about this before,
but I respect so many
foreign service officers
and their work because they,
most of them can
salute the president,
and implement the
policies of the president,
even when they don't
like the president.
And so they can separate that.
I actually always
found it refreshing
to have these political
discussions with people
because the ones who
were really honest about
yeah, I'm a Democrat,
and I think this way,
it was much better because
you could trust them actually.
You could see their work.
- Yeah.
- And you knew they
were implementing.
And so I have great friends
who voted for Biden,
who are foreign
service officers.
And I love talking to them
and it makes a
healthy environment,
but many of them
are admitting to me
that they can't believe
that this is happening.
- So I had Nikki
Haley on last week
and she said something similar.
And she also said something
that you sort of
referenced earlier
about that the world
wants America to lead.
It really desperately does.
It loves to hate on
America in a way,
but also really wants
America to lead.
I sense that's really
what you think too,
that it's like if it's not us,
everybody just runs around
like a chicken without a head.
- Yeah.
I mean, look, I think-
- Or China or China.
- Yeah.
You look at the middle east,
you look at now Europe,
and I would even put the
Latin and south America
in this category.
There's an open admittance
that under Trump,
everything was better.
They're just,
they're literally
able to say that now
more than whisper
and they're right.
- They are right indeed.
I thought you were
giving me a long pause
for a crushing line there.
- They're right.
I mean, what else can you say?
You know, I just-
- So what do you think,
yeah, what do you think Trump
would be doing right now?
I mean, or what
would he have done
for the two weeks before
where Biden basically
coaching Putin in?
What do you think Trump would
have done then, and now.
- So I hate this question
and I, the reason why is,
is because, you know,
now we sit here and we have
to answer the question of
now what would you do
between a terrible and a
really terrible choice?
Look, if I were in charge,
if that's the
hypothetical, right,
if you were in charge,
what would you do?
I was in charge,
we'd kick Joe Biden
out of the White House,
because really what happened was
is Biden led us down
a terrible road.
We gotta turn around and
go back and fix this.
But I'm pissed off
that we have to be
answering these questions of
you know, now what
are your choices
between terrible
and really terrible.
If Donald Trump had been
in charge all along,
we wouldn't be in this
process that we are now
to have a choice between
bad and really bad.
I do think that this
goes back to Afghanistan
and the weakness that was showed
by literally having a
president of the United States
appear to be proud
that he got 90% out.
And the world you know, held
their breath and were shocked.
And they looked at each
other and were like
did he just say that
we left 10% behind
and he's proud of it?
Everybody saw that.
You know, again,
why is secretary of
state Anthony Blinken
still in his job?
He has failed miserably
so many times.
And yet he still has a job.
I don't understand that.
- Well, I think it's because
the media runs cover,
basically what you were saying
before about New York times,
Washington Post and
everything else.
So what do we do about that?
I mean okay, so you
drain the swamp,
you start doing things,
let's say Trump's
magically president again
and you do the things
that the agencies
are talking about.
There's still this media
issue that runs cover.
- Yeah, but you gotta ignore.
- Lies about all the mistakes.
- You gotta just ignore them.
I mean, they all have pay walls,
so don't pay it,
and then you won't read it.
And the reality is
that with social media,
you can educate the public
about what the government
is doing and be transparent.
That's the goal.
The goal is to get information,
transparent information,
honest information to
the American public.
We have developed the
system of a filter
that the media think
that now they are
in charge of information
to the American people.
Social media upended that.
Just like you know, our phones
having our bank accounts on it.
We don't have to go in and
see the teller anymore.
We get to go straight
to our account
and we it to transfer
money and control it.
It's not unlike the media.
And that's why I think
they're clamping down
on getting Trump
off social media.
They don't wanna see a debate.
They want to control it.
So they're applauding it.
It's terrible for this country.
It's why first and second
generation Americans
are the loudest pro
Republican, pro-Trump group
because they left fascism.
They left totalitarianism.
They know what it's like
and they see the
signs with the media.
Some of the proudest members
of the America first crowd
are first and second
generation Americans.
You wanna know who the
problem is in this country,
seventh, eighth
generation white liberals
who haven't traveled enough.
They don't understand
how great America is.
I'd like to have 'em
travel a little bit more.
And then they will stop
tearing our country down
and realize that we're
the greatest country
in the history of the world.
- Yeah, wait, can you
go a little further
on this sort of
second generation,
like the, we're now
seeing a huge explosion
in conservative Latinos.
That's one.
Trump did made major inroads
in the black community.
It's a little unclear where
that sits now at the moment,
but can you talk about that?
Because that seems to me to be
the future of this thing,
not because of the
color of their skin
or even their ethnicity,
but because of the value stuff.
- Yeah, well, look,
I don't even think
that it's just the Hispanics
and Latinos anymore.
You know, certainly we
know the stories of Cubans
who have left
totalitarianism and fascism
and they become this rabid
supporter of freedom,
but it's-
- I'm in Miami man.
Come visit me, you'll see it.
- I have a joke about Miami,
which I can't say 'cause they'll
it hold against me forever,
but it's a very funny one.
I'll tell you personally.
I love Miami and I
love South Florida
because it's so
filled with people
who are freedom fighters.
- Yeah.
- And if you've ever had
a taste of not freedom,
you want freedom.
And so I think what's happening
too, is Eastern Europeans,
Chinese Americans,
Taiwanese Americans,
people who have lived on a-
Russian Americans.
I actually have
some friends in LA
who born and raised in
Russia who live here.
They're some of the most
pro-Trump, positive,
love America Patriots
that you've ever seen
because they are like the
canary in the coal mine
for what's happening
in our society
for institutions that
take away our freedoms.
And I think you've gotta listen
to first and second
generation Americans
tell the story of why
they came to America.
And we have a problem
with those in this country
who don't travel and
who continue to think
you know, I'm gonna write a
big check to BLM or something
because I feel guilty,
and America's a racist country,
and that's not what the people
who are coming here are seeing.
They're seeing a great place
filled with freedom and
democracy and opportunity.
And yet we need to get
these white liberals
who have been here for too long,
who I call fat and happy.
We need to get them traveling
so that they can see
how great America is.
- You know, Rick, you could
correct me if I'm wrong,
but I'm pretty sure that all
of those rich white liberals
in Beverly Hills never voted
to defund their own police.
Isn't that bizarre?
- Of course.
- Really.
- It's not their own.
- You know, you've mentioned
America first a few times.
And I actually,
I spoke at a Republican
congressional event
here in Miami a
couple weeks ago.
It was for about 80
Republican congressmen.
And I was taking
them questions after.
And one them ask me if they felt
that the America first
branding was okay
or was it too,
because of the way the
media talks about it,
was it too associated with
racism or white supremacy
or something?
Obviously I know you
don't think that,
but what do you think that that,
what do you, do you
think there's anything
that has to be done
in terms of branding
so that when people
hear America first
there isn't like some
sort of knee jerk reaction
because of the way the
media talks about it?
- I mean look.
- Or again, it's
ignore the media.
- Yeah. I mean that,
I think you gotta ignore the
media and not play into them.
I mean, they have
silly arguments.
Everything is racist, sexist,
homophobic, you know that,
and I think the more
you just ignore them,
go straight to truth telling,
social media is really powerful
to be able to go
straight to the people,
we gotta do more of that.
We need help from
Republican senators
to fix this big tech problem
of how they try to silence us.
I think we gotta
grow our own media.
I think it's okay to say
that we're always gonna have
media that are on the left
or the right,
that they bring their
personal bias into this.
I think the danger comes when
somebody stands up and says,
I'm unbiased.
I am the arbiter of all things.
And so that person is dangerous
because then you know for
they're a silent liberal.
- Yeah.
Well, scratch your progressive,
find authoritarian.
Sort of backtracking again.
What do you make of just sort of
the world wide response to this?
You know, in the
last couple days
we're banning Russian vodka now,
Chase and Mastercard are booting
Russia from their systems.
There's all this
talk about Swyft.
I mean that the whole
worldwide system,
not just nation states,
but corporations,
everything seems to be
coming down on Russia.
Does it, does that
feel organic to you?
- Look, I think corporate
world is groupthink, right?
I mean, right after January 6th,
this all the
corporations were like
we're not gonna give any
money to any Republican.
And so it's this
reactionary thing.
You know, some of
those same companies
refused to shut down their
operations in Russia.
I think it's okay that
companies are always gonna act
in their own
financial interests.
We understand that they wanna
sell, they wanna make money.
The public has a big
role to play here.
You know, how do we get
people to put pressure
so that human rights and
values become part of it.
And I'm not a purist, you know,
I will go shop at places
where they give most of
their money to Democrats.
I'm not gonna be
one of those people,
but there are moments where I
think you gotta take a stand.
I'm not a big
believer in you know,
saying that we're gonna
boycott certain things,
but I think that you
can use your own power
of your money.
You have the choice.
Right now, I think with
what Russia is doing,
we should apply
financial pressure,
personal financial pressure,
and Swyft and companies
should recognize
that this is a belligerent
moment from this country.
But I also think
that 69 countries
criminalize homosexuality
and some of these same
people who moralize
about oh, I can't do
business with Russia.
They're doing business
with countries
that will put a gay
person in prison
simply because they're gay.
And so where does
that line stop?
I'll also say you know,
I've gotten hit from a
foreign policy establishment
because I said that I
won't sign any letter
that says we should
have a no fly,
you know, implement
a no-fly zone now,
even a humanitarian no-fly zone.
The idea that there's
a light no-fly zone
or partial no-fly
zone is ridiculous.
A no-fly zone is meaning
you're gonna shoot
down a Russian plane.
- You gotta something, yeah.
- Yeah.
And I'm all against that.
I do think though, that
the line in the sand is
a NATO ally.
We have a treaty obligation,
an article five wire is tripped
if there's an attack in
Poland or on a NATO country.
That's a different story
because we got to have,
we gotta have set boundaries
and we've gotta
enforce boundaries.
What you see going on in
Ukraine is heartbreaking though.
It's terrible, I mean, to watch,
but all of the media
are focusing on that.
And I continue to believe
that if the media all
moved to the Congo
and start telling us the stories
of what's going on in the Congo,
there'd be calls from
NATOcons and others
to have a NoFL
zone in the Congo,
and then they'd move
to another country.
And it would just be
this perpetual problem.
What we need to do as Americans
is recognize that the
criteria that we have
is what makes America less safe.
We have to respond to the
national security threats
for America.
Never apologize about
putting America first
because we are largely
a moral country.
I don't think that
we're perfect.
And I'm not saying that,
but I am saying that we
have the best system,
a checks and a balance.
I mean, every month are stats
going out on our economy
and there's a whole industry
that will immediately say
yeah, that number is high
or that number should be lower.
You didn't include this.
We have transparency
in our country.
We should be really
proud of the system
because our system is the best.
While not perfect,
we should never apologize
for this system.
And I think that's
where we have failed,
is we've allowed people
to really tear down
the greatest system and say
it's not the greatest system.
- Rick, you just gave
a beautiful ending,
but I will ask you
one other question,
which is that as a gay,
as they say,
will you come to Florida?
You can bring Matt and
David and the four of us,
we will go out to dinner
and we will say gay in front
of people here in Florida
and see what happens.
Are you willing
to take the risk?
- Let's do it.
We'll be there.
- Good seeing you, my friend.
Thanks for joining.
- All he best.
Thanks, Dave.
- If looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics, instead
of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.